[Musica]
salve a tutti attraverso i confini
dunque la prima cosa che ho pensato
quando ho visto il tema della giornata è
stata la parola idee in fondo conoscete
qualcosa di più straordinario e potente
delle idee nel superare i confini
confini geografici confini del tempo
passando di generazione in generazione
confini del pregiudizio le idee hanno
una straordinaria forza propulsiva e
sembra che sia quasi impossibile alzare
delle barriere o dei muri per impedire
loro di muoversi e le idee come diceva
giovanni falcone che mi piace
particolarmente ricordare in questa
giornata viaggiano e camminano sulle
gambe degli uomini
ecco in questo viaggio breve vorrei
concentrarmi con voi su un particolare
tipo di idee ossia la conoscenza
scientifica la conoscenza tecnica alla
conoscenza specialistica e su quegli
uomini ci sono sulle loro gambe
portatori di questo tipo di conoscenza
quelli che nel dibattito chiamiamo i
cervelli o se preferite i talenti o
ancora con un'espressione molto usata
che però a me non piace tantissimo il
capitale umano
beh non è un gran periodo per parlare di
capitale umano e di cervelli perché
diciamo siamo circondati da studi che ci
dicono che l'analfabetismo funzionale e
dilaga che non riusciamo a leggere testi
più lunghi di tre righe che il nostro
schema di apprendimento e sempre più
visivo e fotografico e sempre meno
analitico e quindi diciamo non andiamo
molto di moda in questi quindici minuti
eppure quello della conoscenza è un
asset fondamentale e vi do un primo
elemento la conoscenza produce ricchezza
se prendiamo i paesi europei e misuriamo
da un lato la crescita del loro
benessere economico
usiamo il pil e dall'altra la
percentuale di laureati che diciamo sul
totale della popolazione giovane giovane
vuol dire fra il
25 ai 34 anni beh ci accorgiamo che le
due cose conoscenza e crescita del
benessere economico viaggiano in
simbiosi viaggiano a braccetto se c'è
luna cresce l'altra è la traiettoria
evolutiva congiunta la vedete
evidenziata da quella retta scura che
visualizzate alle mie spalle non c'è
nessun trucco e nessuna magia la parola
chiave produttività se io ho più
conoscenze il mio lavoro diventa più
efficiente più efficace più produttivo
genera di più con un minore sforzo è
chiaramente questo è un requisito
indispensabile per lo sviluppo economico
pensate che in germania i lavoratori
lavorano in media tra le 30 e le 36 ore
settimanali
noi in italia siamo a 42 beh diciamo
così il nostro pil cresce un po meno del
loro capite mi verrebbe da dire quanto
lavoro per niente quanto sforzo per
niente e la risposta sta lì più
competenze più conoscenze più
produttività e questa è la differenza
fra la germania e noi vi do un modo
diverso di vedere la cosa un po più
micro geograficamente alle mie spalle
vedete il risultato di uno studio che
col mio team all'università cattaneo
liuc e abbiamo chiuso circa un anno fa
ci siamo inventati un indicatore che
misura quanto i territori lombardi sono
attrattivi verso le imprese è la mappa a
sinistra e l'abbiamo messo a confronto
con la distribuzione della conoscenza e
dei cervelli sul territorio colori scuri
azzurri e blu fenomeno sgonfio mentre
dove vedete i gialli rossi quei
territori sono carichi ora è ovvio che
le due mappe non si sovrappongano del
tutto ma guardate quante analogie il
messaggio che ne esce è che la
distribuzione e la presenza di cervelli
e di capitale umano sul territorio
attrae le imprese il che un altro
elemento forte a favore della rilevanza
strategica della conosce
giusto per essere sicuri di non
sbagliarci
abbiamo poi intervistato un bel numero
di imprese del territorio lombardo e
loro ci hanno detto che le scelte
localizzative cioè decidere dove
insediarsi dipendono per quasi il 40 per
cento dalla disponibilità di capitale
umano sul territorio beh direi che è una
cosa straordinaria volete sapere come
siamo messi noi a varese l'istogramma ve
lo dice siamo la seconda provincia
lombarda dopo la città metropolitana
quindi l'enclave milano monza brianza
il che ci pone anche ai primissimi posti
in europa la distribuzione sul
territorio e quella che vedete nelle
mappe quella strana cosa forma di
barbapapà e la provincia di varese
io dico sempre barbapapà i miei studenti
poi sgranano gli occhi e capisco che la
mia datazione al carbonio non si
sovrappone con la loro quindi va beh è
un barbapapà insomma allora il fenomeno
sta il fenomeno si concentra nel cuore
capoluogo e nella pancia ma quello che
più mi interessa è quella se che vedete
dal capoluogo verso il lago maggiore
perché quello è un asse che non è
ricchissimo di imprese però alle imprese
giuste alle imprese che abbiamo
visualizzato sulla destra quelle imprese
che innovano molto e che sono le
protagoniste nell'utilizzo proprio dei
cervelli e della conoscenza
allora facciamo il punto conoscenza vuol
dire ricchezza vuol dire in questo caso
attrazione di imprese vuol dire imprese
innovative ci sarebbero gli ingredienti
per dire investiamo a testa bassa eppure
abbiamo dei problemi
il primo problema sono i luoghi comuni
quante volte avete sentito dire ma serve
ancora studiare serve ancora avere un
titolo di studio
la risposta equa l'occupazione giovanile
in italia e al di sotto del 40 per cento
per chi è portatore di un titolo di
scuola superiore
sale a quasi il 50 per cento e per chi
ha una laurea sale a quasi il 65 per
cento gli stessi numeri valgono per
tutta l'europa e per tutti i paesi
europei
l'importante però è che la conoscenza
sia quella
giusta quella che le imprese cercano e
anche qui abbiamo un problema perché da
un indagine ocse scopriamo che il 60 per
cento dei lavoratori italiani a un
livello di qualifica e di competenze che
non è adeguato al tipo di mansione che
svolge
o è troppo elevato o è troppo scarso è
semplicemente diverso quindi il lavoro e
lo studio a volte anzi spesso si
incontrano poco poi abbiamo un terzo
problema questo forse il più grave di
tutti che alla fine di laureati ne
produciamo troppo pochi e siamo
sistematicamente in coda a tutte le
graduatorie dei paesi industrializzati
sia in totale si sa se ci limitiamo a
guardare le generazioni più giovani cioè
quelle che hanno tra 24 e 33 25 34 anni
e infine l'ultimo problema che è questo
anche quando i laureati e i cervelli li
produciamo ce li facciamo scappare
questa mappa dell'europa vi racconta
quali sono i flussi di cervelli nel
territorio europeo
i paesi scuri sono quelli che attraggono
il pallone dell'italia è sconcertante e
in italia anche la lombardia purtroppo
in questo caso a un colorino proprio
pallido pallido che fa un po venire i
brividi
il problema c'è il problema è il gap tra
la rilevanza strategica dell'asse
conoscenza dell'asse cervelli e
dall'altra parte queste difficoltà che
abbiamo nel vincere la scommessa della
conoscenza
ora mi viene da fare una proposta
naturalmente retorica detta qui ma molto
concreta non appena avremo finito questa
chiacchierata ed è quella di un patto
territoriale per la conoscenza in cui
tutti facciano la loro parte
la dovrebbero fare le imprese che
dovrebbero come dire aprire di più le
porte a certe figure professionali e
soprattutto guardare a quel tipo di
produzioni altamente innovative che così
tanto intensivamente usano la conoscenza
la dovrebbe fare il sistema pubblico
privato
mettendo magari qualche risorsa in più
non solo per la ricerca in sé ma per le
borse di studio per favorire i giovani
che hanno voglia di studiare e i
laureati che hanno voglia di continuare
a fare un'attività di questo tipo e
dovrebbero farla le università tutte qui
ci sono solo alcuni punti che ci
interesserebbe far crescere e sviluppare
coinvolgere di più i giovani nella
costruzione dei progetti formativi
arricchire la nostra attività didattica
di esperienze concrete più di quanto già
per esempio noi nel nostro piccolo
cerchiamo di fare lavorare più a stretto
contatto quelle imprese soprattutto
quelle medio piccole
e poi la formazione permanente cioè
guardare anche a quei signori che il
titolo di studio l'hanno portato a casa
magari qualche annetto fa ma lo voglia
di aggiornarsi di crescere di maturare
nuove consapevolezze anche a livello
professionale
ora ma ripeto la proposta può sembrare
un pochettino retorica e qualcuno starà
pensando ma davvero serve a qualcosa
questa cosa qua beh vi do l'ultimo
blocco di numeri esiste ed è stata
pubblicata di recente una ricerca
europea che ci dice che l'insieme di
tutte le università europee ha generato
nel 2017 sono gli ultimi dati
disponibili circa 400 miliardi di euro
di valore aggiunto è un concetto è anche
un ordine di grandezza che forse per noi
è un po difficile calare a terra e
allora che cosa abbiamo provato a fare
noi e luke nel nostro piccolo clonare
quell'algoritmo e provare a ragionare su
di noi e quello che abbiamo tirato fuori
lo vedete alle mie spalle ogni 100
laureati che escono dalle nostre aule
noi riusciamo ad attivare più che noi
loro un serie di circuiti economici
virtuosi che tradotti in termini diciamo
finanziario monetari equivalgono a cento
quasi 100 milioni
di euro di pil questo dato vi risulta
ancora poco facile da far atterrare sul
pianeta
allora vi dall ultimo che credo diciamo
così sia la vera chiave di volta questa
roba a un'implicazione a livello
occupazionale pil vuol dire posti di
lavoro
e allora ci siamo inventati il
moltiplicatore dei cervelli
cioè ci siamo chiesti ma per ogni
laureato che produciamo i circuiti
economici che questo fanciullo o questa
fanciulla attiva sviluppa sostiene nutre
generano posti di lavoro certo che sì
l'economia che questi circuiti attivano
generano posti genera posti di lavoro e
il numero questo ogni laureato 250 posti
di lavoro la parola moltiplicatore mi
sembra funzioni bene uno a 250 ed è
perfetta quando si parla di idee di
conoscenza di cervelli la parola
moltiplicazione perfetta ricordate
georges bernanos e due uomini che hanno
una mela si incontrano e si scambiano la
mela
ognuno va a casa con due mele ma se si
scambiano con una mela scusate se si
scambiano un'idea vanno entrambi a casa
con due idee
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]